[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien schönen guten Abend alles
was wichtig ist und wird in den nächsten
20 Minuten Katja sportliches gehört
natürlich dazu natürlich einen schönen
guten Abend auch von mir wir starten die
Sendung mit einer laufenden und
gefährlichen evakuierungsmission
Rettung aus dem Sudan
bundeswehrmaschinen bringen hunderte
Menschen in Sicherheit darunter viele
Deutsche
Windkraft für Europa Deutschland und
weitere Länder wollen die Nordsee zum
grünen Kraftwerk machen
[Musik]
Berlin Aktivisten der Gruppe letzte
Generation stören den Verkehr in der
Hauptstadt
[Musik]
wenn deutsche Elite Soldaten und die
GSG9 beteiligt sind dann wissen Sie es
ist ein hochgefährlicher Einsatz so wie
die aktuell laufende Rettungsmission im
krisengeschüttelten Sudan Ziel der
Bundeswehr vorrangig deutsche
Staatsbürger in Sicherheit bringen über
300 Personen konnte die Luftwaffe
inzwischen Ausfliegen gut 100 landeten
in Berlin zum Erfolg und zu den Risiken
der Operation Patricia Wiedemeier
die Evakuierung aus dem Sudan sie läuft
auf Hochtouren heute morgen kurz nach
sechs landete die erste
Bundeswehrmaschine in Berlin über 300
Menschen aus Deutschland und aus 20
weiteren Staaten wurden bisher
ausgeflogen ein Flugzeug sei noch
unterwegs 400 evakuierte könnten es
heute am Abend sein das erklärten die
Außenministerin und der
Verteidigungsminister wie es weitergeht
fraglich da die Feuerpause heute Abend
zu Ende geht
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass wir uns
damit ab heute Abend in einer anderen
Lage befinden werden ob die
Sicherheitslage in den nächsten Tagen
weitere Evakuierung erlauben wird ist
mehr als ungewiss sie haben es geschafft
sind heute morgen in Berlin gelandet sie
wollten Afrika zu Fuß durchqueren saßen
als die Kämpfe begannen in cartoon fest
sieben Tage hatten sie keinen Strom kein
Internet keine Infos kein Ort in der
Stadt sei sicher gewesen es war
ungarisch schwer zu planen weil jede
geht es Abkommen wurde quasi im Moment
des Abkommens wieder gebrochen manchmal
hat es von der einen Seite geschossen
manchmal von der anderen es gab vorher
mal hier mal da das ist emotional
schwierig vor allen Dingen wenn sie von
der Information abgeschnitten sind
einige Deutsche haben die Hauptstadt
auch auf anderen Wegen verlassen zum
Beispiel mit einem Konvoi der Vereinten
Nationen in die Hafenstadt Portugal
daher ist noch unklar wie viele Deutsche
immer noch im Land sind aber der
bisherige Verlauf deutlich besser und
koordinierter als die Evakuierung 2021
aus Afghanistan
1000 Männer und Frauen der deutschen
Bundeswehr waren und sind im Einsatz im
Nahen Osten und in Afrika wir waren auf
jede Situation vorbereitet die
Bundeswehr hatte in beispielhafte Art
und Weise gezeigt wie kaltstartfähig sie
ist wie schnell Sie sich auf eine solche
Situationen einstellen kann wie jeder
Einsatz der Parlamentsarmee muss dieser
vom Bundestag gebilligt werden
normalerweise vorher diesmal dürfte die
nachträgliche Zustimmung wohl kein
Problem sein
und wir gehen zu Luke wahlport nach
Kairo Lück also über 150 deutsche
konnten schon ausgeflogen werden sind
jetzt alle deutsche außer Landes
nein das sind sie nicht wir wissen nicht
genau wie hoch die Zahl oder wie groß
die Zahl von deutschen Staatsbürgern
noch ist die sich noch im Land befinden
aber das Auswärtige Amt wird diese Zahl
auch nicht mitteilen es ist halt
schwierig geworden an die Menschen
ranzukommen denn die Versorgungslage ist
dramatisch insbesondere in den
umkämpften Gebieten dazu gehören große
Teile der Hauptstadt cartoum das
internet bricht immer wieder zusammen es
gibt kaum noch Strom Wasser und
Lebensmittel auch nicht und wenn man an
Strom Wasser Lebensmittel kommt sind die
Preise explodiert und das heißt auch für
Benzin und damit sind auch
Fluchtbewegungen oder sich einfach in
andere Viertel aufzubrechen ist gar
nicht mehr so einfach und ist richtig
lebensgefährlich denn die Kämpfe gehen
weiter man muss übrigens auch damit
rechnen dass man möglicherweise an einem
Kontrollpunkt an einem Kontrollpunkt von
Soldaten dann geplündert wird oder das
Fahrzeug abgenommen wird also eine sehr
schwierige Lage also das bleibt noch
komplett danke schön nach Kairo das war
Lück wahlport ja was bedeuten die Kämpfe
im Sudan für die ganze Region
antworten auf diese und andere wichtige
Fragen zum Konflikt finden sie auf ZDF
heute oder in unserer App
insgesamt wurden ja bisher über 1.000
Menschen ausgeflogen durch Bundeswehr
und westliche Partner die sich
untereinander gut abgesprochen haben das
war großes Thema beim
EU-Außenministertreffen in Luxemburg
eigentlich wollte man hauptsächlich
reden über munitionslieferungen an die
Ukraine und wie man da mehr Tempo macht
aber erst mal allgemeine Erleichterung
über die bislang erfolgreiche
sudan-mission Florian an eine Sitzung
mit so vielen Krisen Themen könne er
sich nicht erinnern sagt Giuseppe am
Abend aber immerhin in einer Krise beim
Sudan kann der EU-Außenbeauftragte einen
Erfolg vermelden mehr als 1200
evakuierte EU-Bürger
das hat alle meine Erwartungen
übertroffen 30 Flüge in zwei Tagen
denken wir aber auch an die Menschen die
nicht evakuiert werden können und die im
Sudan leben das ist eine große große
Katastrophe die EU appelliert an die
Kriegsparteien im Sudan aufzuhören hat
ansonsten aber nicht viel in der Hand
anders beim zweiten großen Thema dieses
Treffens der Munition für die Ukraine wo
sich die Minister eigentlich vor vier
Wochen schon geeinigt hatten für eine
Milliarde Euro erstmals gemeinsam
Munition zu kaufen doch seitdem gibt es
Streit über die Umsetzung Frankreich
verlangt die Munition nur in Europa bei
der eigenen Rüstungsindustrie zu kaufen
andere sagen hauptsache man kauft
überhaupt und nicht nur der
zugeschaltete ukrainische Außenminister
ist langsam verärgert
wenn wir weiter verzögern kann die
Ukraine nicht so schnell vorankommen
deshalb ist unsere Geschwindigkeit jetzt
der entscheidende Faktor
er rechne mit einer Einigung in den
nächsten Tagen sagt der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell am Abend und
bereite währenddessen alles vor damit
Europa nicht weiter Zeit verliert
der Konflikt in der Ukraine bestimmte
heute auch die Beratungen im
UN-Sicherheitsrat in New York russland
hat hier in diesem Monat turnusmäßig den
Vorsitz der russische Außenminister
lavrov leitete das Treffen selbst und
nutzte das um den Einmarsch in der
Ukraine erneut zu verteidigen den USA
und der NATO war vor die Weltordnung
beherrschen zu wollen es geht nicht um
die Ukraine es geht darum wie
internationale Beziehungen in Zukunft
geführt werden wird es einen Konsens auf
der Grundlage des Ausgleichs der
Interessen aller geben oder auf der
Grundlage der aggressiven Strebens der
USA nach vorher schaffen so lavroff
sprechen wir darüber mit Johannes Hanau
in New York wieder scharfe
Anschuldigungen Richtung Westen wie
fällt das Echo auf die Laufräder aus
also erstmal gab es in der Rede nicht
wirklich überraschend neues
bemerkenswert war der unversöhnliche
Tonfall in dem Lauf auf seine Argumente
hier vorgetragen hat er hat den
demokratischen Gesellschaften
vorgeworfen dass sie versuchen würden
das UN-System zu missbrauchen um mit
ihren Vorstellungen von einer
demokratischen regelbasierten
Weltordnung den Rest der Welt zu
dominieren das ganze wurde geächelt von
China die zwar im Tonfall etwas milder
waren aber in der Sache genauso hart die
demokratischen das demokratische Lager
hingegen hat gesagt das hat ganze Zeit
zynisch das ausgerechnet Russland dieses
Treffen hier einberufen habe zu
Verteidigung der un-kartner ein Land das
die Karte der Vereinten Nationen mit
Füßen trete interessant war dann aber
doch noch ganz am Ende das eigentlich
alle Staaten gesagt haben wir müssen die
Vereinten Nationen reformieren das
System seit dysfunktional geworden das
würde dieser Konflikt zeigen aber ich
glaube so wie die Sache die sich heute
dargestellt hat wird man sich wie die
ganze Sache hier reformiert werden soll
so schnell nicht eigentlich werden
vielen Dank Johannes
von New York geht jetzt an die Nordsee
die sollen nämlich bis 2050 zum größten
Energielieferanten Europas werden und
wie das gelingen kann darüber beraten 9
europäische Länder auf ihrem
nordseegipfel im belgischen Ostende
Einweg ist der massive Ausbau von
Offshore Windparks man will die
Windkraft noch effizienter nutzen und
plant darum künstliche energieinseln wie
die diese hier etwa 400 m lang durch ein
Fundament fest am Meeresboden verankert
von Betonmauern und geben um vor Wind
und Wellen sicher zu sein an diesem
Drehkreuz wird 45 km vor der belgischen
Küste der Strom der umliegenden
Windkraftanlagen gesammelt gebündelt und
dann zum Festland transportiert das ist
effizienter und kostengünstiger mit mehr
die Kulisse ist ein Kabelleger eins der
Schiffe die Europas Energiewende bauen
nordsee-gipfel diesmal in Ostende mit
mehr Teilnehmern die sich höhere
Ausbauziele setzen 120 Gigawatt bis 2030
300 Gigawatt bis 2050 das ist möglich
dies in einem großen europäischen
Verbund über Ländergrenzen hinweg zu tun
ganz kurzer Zeit wird die Nordsee noch
viel mehr als wir das heute schon wissen
der wichtige Ort der Energieproduktion
sein doch für Windparks of Shore draußen
im Meer für letztes Jahr in der ganzen
Nordsee keine einzige Neubau
Entscheidung der Gastgeber muss deshalb
zugeben
ist das wichtigste Thema ist wie kommen
wir in die Umsetzung wir brauchen
gemeinsame Standards müssen uns besser
absprechen und unsere Lieferketten viel
besser Takten
eine Modell von Belgiens energieinsel
müssen darum alle vorbei Kabel bündeln
und Netze verknüpfen so weit so einig
doch der Energie Mix darin ist nicht
derselbe siehe Frankreich
zu werden bauen wir auf drei Pfeile
Energie einsparen die Erneuerbaren und
die kernenecke die aber verstopfte das
Netz für erneuerbare sagt mancher der
hier mit ein Wort geht was zeigt da
gibt's noch einiges abzusprechen
vor der nordafrikanischen Küste sind in
den letzten Tagen wieder mehrere Boote
mit Flüchtlingen in Not geraten etwa 800
Menschen erreichten die italienische
Insel Lampedusa und 20 Menschen werden
vermisst gleichzeitig wurden von der
tunesischen Küstenwache 31 Leichen
gefunden die Zusammenhänge werden
derzeit geprüft das Auffanglager in
Lampedusa ist völlig überfüllt ausgelegt
ist es für 400 Personen aktuell halten
sich dort mehr als 1.000 auf
wieder nach Deutschland gestern hat die
Berliner SPD der schwarz-roten Koalition
zugestimmt heute zog die CDU nach sie
sprach sich einstimmig für das neue
Bündnis in der Hauptstadt aus bereits
zuvor hatte der designierte Regierende
Bürgermeister Kai Wegner Fehler
badenberg die parteilose Vizepräsidentin
des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz
als neue Justizsenatorin nominiert spd-
dann bleiben wir in Berlin da hatten die
klimaaktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation für heute angekündigt die
Hauptstadt lahm zu legen die Polizei hat
alles das zu verhindern an rund 30 Orten
gab es Straßenblockaden und andere
protestet als stundenlange Staus die
Folge in denen auch Rettungsfahrzeuge
feststecken henrietisier
es braucht gar nicht viele Aktivistinnen
und Aktivisten um an einem Montagmorgen
den Berliner Berufsverkehr lahm zu legen
klimaprotest in der Hauptstadt heute
morgen die Gemüter erhitzt
ich habe für Anliegen Verständnis aber
für die Art und Weise überhaupt nicht es
geht nicht an das irgendwelche selbst
ernannten Weltretter glauben den
deutschen starterpressen zu dürfen
[Musik]
die wie sie sich nennen letzte
Generation hatte angekündigt die Stadt
lahm zu legen sie wollen Druck machen
auf die Politik den Klimaschutz
voranzubringen das Zeitfenster in dem
wir eine Katastrophe den Kollaps unserer
Gesellschaft noch abwenden können das
schließlich wenn ich von Katastrophe
spreche dann spreche ich davon dass
unsere ernten ausfallen werden dann
spricht davon dass das Wasser knapp wird
zeitweise sind laut Polizeiangaben an
bis zu 30 Orten im Stadtgebiet
klimaproteste auch die Stadtautobahn auf
ganzen Abschnitten Namen gelegt
Kilometer lange Staus wenn die Autos
keine Rettungsgasse bilden haben es auch
die Retter schwer
es kamen zu einer Vielzahl von Staus das
können wir sagen aktuell zumindest mein
letzter Stand war das auch 20
Rettungsfahrzeuge im Stau standen die
Berliner und Berliner die sich heute im
Stadtverkehr bewegen werden das ein oder
andere auch mitbekommen haben an
Behinderung auch am Nachmittag gab es
wieder Aktionen die letzte Generation
sie hat angekündigt weiterzumachen
ja und zu den klimaprotesten gibt es
heute auch ein ZDF heute live ab 19 Uhr
30 dort diskutieren dann ein grünen
Politiker und ein Aktivist und zu sehen
das ganze auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen oder aber auf der ZDF heute App
besonders klimafreundlich weil 100%
emissionsfrei ist das fahren mit dem
Fahrrad eine Alternative die immer
beliebter wird aber nicht überall sind
die Voraussetzungen optimal der
Allgemeine Deutsche Fahrradclub der ADFC
fragt jedes Jahr online nach wo sind die
Radler am zufriedensten knapp eine
viertel Millionen Interessierte haben
diesmal abgestimmt und die Umfrage zeigt
in einigen Städten ist noch Luft nach
oben Markus aus
zu schmale Radwege zugeparkte
Fahrradstreifen Köln macht es den
Radfahrer nicht leicht wenig
überraschend die Menschen in Köln sind
mit der fahrradinfrastruktur unzufrieden
das belegt auch der heute vom
allgemeinen deutschen Fahrradclub
vorstellte fahrradklima Test
grundsätzlich ist es ein Trend den wir
mit Sorge beobachten dass das
fahrradklima weiter unbefriedigend ist
und das ist jetzt keine Aussage des ADFC
sondern das sind wirklich die Ergebnisse
von
245.000 Menschen in Deutschland bei den
Großstädten mit über 500.000 Einwohnern
liegt Bremen auf Platz 1 in Sachen
Zufriedenheit mit der Radinfrastruktur
gefolgt von Frankfurt am Main und
Hannover die Schlusslichter sind Köln
Dortmund und Essen
trotz schlechter Gesamtplatzierung
immerhin eine gute Nachricht für Köln
der ADFC prämiert die Stadt als
stärksten aufholer Beispiel
Komödienstraße aus ehemals vier Spuren
für Autos oder eine Einbahnstraße mit
großzügigen Radwegen
sehr gut 18 Jahre jetzt ungefähr gleich
arbeite Stelle und das jetzt merke ich
dass sie ich bin entspannt
zu Anfang finde ich schon zum zweiten
Mal in Folge geht der Titel für die
fahrradfreundlichste Gemeinde
Deutschlands an Wettringen im
Münsterland nicht zuletzt wegen eines 21
km langen Radweges mit Vorfahrtsrecht
immerhin ja wieder eine Nervenprobe für
Flugreisende in Hamburg und Berlin in
Hamburg rief Verdi Teile des
Bodenpersonals kurzfristig dazu auf die
Arbeit niederzulegen angekündigt
hingegen war der Warnstreik des
Sicherheitspersonals am Flughafen in
Berlin er endet um Mitternacht alle rund
220 geplanten Abflüge wurden hier
gestrichen wer die verhandelt über
Zuschläge etwa für Nacht und
feiertagsarbeit
so Sonntagsarbeit gab es gestern für
sechs Vereine der Fußball-Bundesliga
Katja und in der geht es nicht nur im
Meisterschaftsrennen spannend zu sondern
auch im Kampf um die Champions League
Plätze Freiburg hat sich gestern wieder
einen ergattert durch ein 4:0 gegen
Schalke und auch Union Berlin steht gut
da aktuell auf Rang 3 der Tabelle
nur vier Punkte liegen sie hinter Bayern
München Union Berlin kommt zum Sieg bei
Borussia Mönchengladbach durch ein Tor
von Gerald Becker nach einer Stunde 16
Saison sie haben sie jetzt nur Dortmund
und die Bayern haben mehr hinten spielen
sie zu 0 Union bleibt als Tabellen
Dritter des Bundesliga-Team mit den
wenigsten gegen Treffern mehr hat sich
dem Punkt an dem man gar nicht mehr
anders kann als in der Champions League
zu spielen
davon hat sich RB Leipzig in Weiß nach
der Niederlage in Leverkusen etwas
entfernt Adam Loschek bringt Bayer kurz
vor der Pause in Führung der Europa
League Halbfinalist hält dem Leipziger
Druck auch nach der Pause stand Dominik
soboslai sieht Gelb Rot Kurzschluss nach
einem faul im eigenen Strafraum nadimiri
trifft zum 20 für Leverkusen Leipzig
verliert den Champions League Platz am
Freiburg der SC ist jetzt vierter zwei
Punkte voraus
ja und alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des 29
Spieltags können Sie wie immer
zusammengefasst sehen unter heute.de und
in der heute App ja und noch dies beim
Ocean Race der Segel Regatta um die Welt
sind die Boote nach einer zweiwöchigen
Pause nun auf der vierten Etappe
unterwegs es geht von Brasilien in die
USA Boote und Segelteams sind wieder
frisch nur einer fehlt Boris Hermann der
deutsche skip von Hamburg aus mit
Hermann verbringt etwas Zeit mit seiner
Familie 24 Stunden nach dem Start im
brasilianischen Itachi liegt die malizia
mit ersatzkipper will Harris auf Rang 2
hinter der im gesamten plasmoor
führenden Schweizer Yacht Holz in die
deutsche Alicia will in den nächsten
zwei einhalb Wochen auf dem Weg ins
US-amerikanische Newport mit einem neuen
Spinnaker weiter Boden gut machen Mitte
Mai wird dann auch Boris Hermann wieder
an Bord gehen
und der hat ja dann noch drei Etappen
vor sich danke Katja ja jetzt noch ein
paar eher ungewöhnliche impressionen zur
Spargelsaison im belgischen Wald
hallabos sieht die nämlich so aus blau
lila immer im April blühen dort
zigtausende Hasenglöckchen aus der
Familie der spargelgewächse nichts zum
Essen nur zum gucken und staunen und
dabei auch wunderbare Art flüchtig ein
zwei Wochen noch dann ist der
Zauberteppich schon wieder verblüht und
quasi weg
ja für Blümchen können es aber noch mal
gefährlich werden es drohen nämlich
Nachtfröste ob schon heute Nacht
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja vorne
fahren um 21:45 Uhr empfehle ich Ihnen
das heute journal mit Christian Sievers
das war's von uns danke und noch einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend im westlichen Niedersachsen
und in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat es heute
kräftig geregnet das hing zusammen mit
den tief Udo das inzwischen über Fehmarn
liegt bis morgen Abend sieht es weiter
Richtung Südschweden und macht den Platz
frei für das hochquini und das bringt
uns dann Bodenfrost in der Nacht auf
Mittwoch und auf Donnerstag heute Nacht
fällt häufig Regen und in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen oberhalb von etwa 600 bis
900 Meter kann sogar mal etwas
Schneefall die Temperaturen sinken auf 7
Grad am Oberrhein aber auch hier
nördlichen Brandenburg und an der Ostsee
und bis 0 Grad im Westerwald kalt bleibt
es morgen an den Alpen da liegen die
Höchstwerte nur bei 7 Grad am Mittel
unter Niederrhein sind es immerhin 12
Grad das gibt morgen klassisches
Aprilwetter also kräftige Regenschauer
zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen
Sonne und das bei einem starken zum Teil
stürmischen Wind aus Nordwest länger
regnet es morgen im Schwarzwald auch am
alten Rand und hier in Niederbayern
können sich aus auch mal Gewitter dabei
sein am Mittwoch geht's dann häufiger
Sonnenschein in der Nacht eben den
Bodenfrost auch in der Nacht auf
Donnerstag wird es sehr kalt dann wird
es deutlich milder aber zum Freitag
kommt schon wieder neuer Regen und es
gibt auch Gewitter guten Abend